RICHARD FOWLER, JESSE WATTERS.
HER iPHONE IS HER FULL-LENGTH
MIRROR.
DANA PERINO.
"THE FIVE" ."
THE MEDIA TAKE ON 2017.
THANK GOD IT'S OVER.
SO MUCH CHAOS, SO MUCH FEAR.
NO WONDER CNN HIT THE BOMB LIKE
A BABBLING DEADHEAD.
FAKE NEWS WILL DO THAT TO YOU.
HOW MUCH OF THIS FEELING IS
WARRANTED?
2017 WAS BAD FOR ISIS WHICH
MEANS GOOD FOR US.
2017 WAS BAD FOR NORTH KOREA WHO
FACED NEW PRESSURE FROM OLD
PALS.
THAT'S GOOD FOR US.
2017 WAS BAD FOR PESSIMISTS AS
CONSUMER CONFIDENCE RETURN.
THAT'S GOOD FOR US.
2017 WAS BAD FOR OUR OTHER
GLOBAL RIVALS.
THAT'S GOOD FOR US.
2017 WAS BAD FOR THE MEDIA,
UNDER FIVE OVER -- UNDER FIRE
OVER BIAS AND UNDERMINE MY
TWITTER.
YOU ARE KEEPING THEM ON THEIR
TOES.
GOOD FOR YOU.
2017 WAS BAD FOR COLLEGES
PLAGUED BY SOCIAL JUSTICE
TYRANNY.
AS THE WEB CONTINUE TO OFFER
FREE CURRICULUM TO EVERYONE
CRACKING THE MONOPOLY OF
ACADEMIA, GOOD FOR YOU.
2017 WAS BAD FOR COUNTRIES GET
THAT'S GOOD FOR US FRACTURES.
27 HE WAS BAD FOR DESPAIR.
POVERTY DECLINED AT HEALTH
IMPROVED.
27 HE WAS BAD FAR BEEN WANTING
WHICH IS GOOD FOR EVERYONE ELSE.
THERE WERE AWFUL EVENTS AND
US.
THEY APPEAR EVERY YEAR AND THEY
WILL DO SO IN 2018 SADLY BUT
LOOKING AHEAD, LET'S NOT FUDGE
WHAT'S BEEN LEFT BEHIND.
IT'S NOT AS BAD AS THEY WANT YOU
KEEP YOUR CHIN UP.
ALL RIGHT, JESSE.
THAT WAS A LOOK BACK.
WE KNOW HISTORY WILL SEE THIS
DIFFERENT THAN THE MEDIA DID.
WHAT'S YOUR FEELING?
MR. PURPLE GUY.
>> Jesse: NOT PURPLE.
MAGENTA.
I LIKE THE WAY YOU SAID FRACKERS
I LIKE THE WAY YOU SAID FRACKER
FRACKERS.
I THINK TRUMP HAS A VERY CLEAR
VISION OF WHAT HE WANTS TO
ACCOMPLISH ANY NEEDS HELP FROM
THE LEGISLATURE.
HE DID ALL HE COULD EXECUTIVE
LEE THIS PAST YEAR AND THE TWO
BIG WINS AT THE END CAME THROUGH
HELP FROM THE LEGISLATURE.
INFRASTRUCTURE IS WHAT HE WANTS
AND NATURALLY REAL ESTATE TYCOON
AND DEVELOPER, HE'S GOING TO
OBVIOUSLY TAKE HUGE INTEREST IN
STIMULUS PLAN WHERE IT WAS
$1 TRILLION FOR SHOVEL READY
PROJECTS THAT WERE NEVER SHOVEL
READY.
TRUMP HAS ALWAYS BEEN SOMEONE
WHO'S GOING TO DO THINGS ON TIME
AND UNDER BUDGET.
THE ASSET FOR HIM AS YOU GET TO
LEAVE THE WHITE HOUSE AND
CAMPAIGN FOR THESE THINGS AND
SWING DISTRICTS.
THE PITCH IS GOING TO BE DUMB
POLITICIANS HAVE WASTED
TRILLIONS IN THE SANDBOX IN THE
MIDDLE EAST WITH NOTHING TO SHOW
FOR IT.
LET'S REBUILD THE COUNTRY.
IT ALSO WOOS BLUE-COLLAR AND
MIDDLE-CLASS VOTERS.
HE CUT THEIR TAXES.
I WAS GOING TO SPEND MONEY.
FORCE THE DEMOCRATS TO SAY
WHETHER THEY WOULD VOTE WITH
CHUCK AND NANCY OR FOR PEOPLE.
THEY HAVE ON THE ONE HAND
MIDDLE-CLASS PEOPLE WHOSE WAGES
GO DOWN THROUGH OPEN BORDERS.
I THINK A LOT OF UNION PEOPLE
WANT THE WALL BUILT THEN YOU
HAVE A VERY LOUD HISPANIC
ACTIVISTS WERE GOING TO DONATE A
LOT OF MONEY AND THEY'RE
PROBABLY GOING TO TIE THEMSELVES
TO BOLD OVERS -- BULLDOZERS.
THE REPUBLICANS WANT TO END
CHAIN MIGRATION IN THE LOTTERY
SYSTEM BECAUSE OF BUSINESS OR
IDEOLOGY, SOME OF THEM AREN'T
CRAZY ABOUT THE WALL.
TRUMP HAS THE TRUMP CARD.
FOR SIX MONTHS AND PULL THE RUG
OUT.
I GUESS THE WILD CARD IS EITHER
MUELLER OR CRAZY WEATHER OR SOME
PRETTY GOOD.
>> Richard: I AM CHECKING TO
SEE IF YOU HAVE A FEVER FROM
BEING OUT IN TIMES SQUARE FOR
SHOVEL-READY BUDDIES USING THE
SHOVEL TO BASH EVERYBODY CAN'T
STAND.
IT'S KIND OF REFRESHING.
>> Richard: I DON'T KNOW IF I
FEEL THE SAME WAY.
I THINK IT SOUNDS GOOD.
MEANWHILE, BACK AT THE RANCH,
YOU HAVE REAL PROBLEMS.
IN THE STATES TRUMP WON, OHIO,
INDIANA, MICHIGAN.
THOSE THREE STATES, THE
UNEMPLOYMENT NUMBERS ARE UP.
TRUMP DOESN'T HAVE ANYTHING TO
SOLVE THE FEARS OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS.
JOBS AREN'T GOING BACK THERE AND
HE HASN'T FOUND A WAY TO FIX IT.
>> Jesse: UP FROM WHEN?
>> Richard: 2017, UNEMPLOYMENT
NUMBERS HAVE GONE UP IN THOSE
PLACES.
LESS JOBS.
MICHIGAN, LESS JOBS.
INDIANA, OHIO.
CHECK IT.
FEWER JOBS.
>> Jesse: I WILL.
C7 CHECK MY GRAMMAR BUT THERE AE
FEWER JOBS IN THESE PLACES TRUMP
SAID HE WAS GOING TO BRING
JOBS AND MAKE AMERICA
GREAT FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS.
WHAT HE'S GOING TO HAVE TO DO
IS -- IS NUMBER ONE STUMBLING
BLOCK IS HE'S GOING TO HAVE
McCAIN, FLAKE, FROM TENNESSEE.
CORKER.
HE'S GOING TO NEED THEM AND HE
DOESN'T HAVE THEM.
ON TOP OF THE FACT THAT THE TAX
BILL ADDS $1.5 TRILLION TO THE
DEFICIT.
ANY INFRASTRUCTURE BILL THAT
PASSES IS GOING TO ADD MORE AND
HE'S GOING TO HAVE A PROBLEM
GETTING THESE THREE REPUBLICANS
DEMOCRATS.
>> Greg: I LOVE IT WHEN
LIBERALS START TALKING ABOUT
DEBT.
INFRASTRUCTURE.
DO YOU WANT ME TO PLAY IT?
SAY PLEASE.
>> Kimberly: PLEASED, PRETTY
PLEASE.
>> BORDER SECURITY, WELFARE
REFORM.
WHICH IS THE PRIMARY FOCUS?
>> THE PRESIDENT WAS ELECTED
BECAUSE OF HIS AMBITIOUS AGENDA
AND HIS IS TO HIRE -- DESIRE TO
GET A LOT OF THINGS DONE.
A LOT OF THE MEETINGS THE
PRESIDENT HAS THIS WEEK WILL
HELP DETERMINE WHAT THE BEST
STRATEGY IS ON EACH OF THOSE
AREAS.
THOSE ARE CERTAINLY WELFARE
REFORM, INFRASTRUCTURE,
RESPONSIBLE IMMIGRATION REFORM
IN HEALTH CARE WILL ALL BE TOP
PRIORITIES.
>> Greg: OF THOSE ARE BIG
>> Kimberly: BIG PRIORITIES
AND AMBITIOUS OBJECTIVES HE'S
TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH.
THIS IS WHAT HE PROMISED.
SUPPOSED TO BE A TRANSFORMATIVE
CANDIDATE AND PRESIDENT AND MAKE
SURE THINGS GOT DONE, DRAIN THE
SWAMP IN D.C.
I SPENT DIFFICULTY TRYING TO
BUILD CONSENSUS IN THE PAST BUT
I THINK FRESH OFF THIS TAX
REFORM WIN AND BEING ABLE TO
GUESS POSITIVE ABOUT IT.
NO, I THINK YOU SHOULD.
EVERYBODY KNOWS WE NEED CHANGES
IN THESE AREAS.
EVERYBODY HAS BEEN TRYING FOR SO
LONG TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT
IMMIGRATION, ONE OF THE BIGGEST
THINGS HE CAMPAIGNED ON AND I
THINK THERE'S GOING TO BE
STRENGTH GOING FORWARD, STRONG
ECONOMY AND JOB NUMBERS, GDP.
TAX REFORM IS GOING TO HELP
PUSHING THOSE RESULTS FORWARD.
IS MORE DOABLE NOW THAT WHAT
HAPPENED WITH TAX REFORM.
>> Greg: DANA, TAKE IT ALL
HOME.
TALKING ABOUT HOW TODAY GOING
FROM THE MOST PROGRESSIVE
PRESIDENT TO PROBABLY THE MOST
CONSERVATIVE PRESIDENT SINCE
REAGAN.
I DIDN'T HAVE ANY IDEA WHAT
TRUMP BELIEVED.
>> Dana: ONE OF THE REASONS I
THINK PEOPLE WERE SAYING GOODBYE
TO 2017 WASN'T NECESSARILY THAT
IT WAS BAD FOR ALL THE REASONS
EXHAUSTING AND DIFFERENT AND NE
NEW.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS DISRUPTIVE
AND IT TOOK ABOUT A YEAR FOR
PEOPLE TO GET USED TO IT.
NOW YOU SEE TWEETS AND YOU ARE
LIKE WHATEVER.
SOMETIMES THEY ARE NEWSWORTHY.
OTHER TIMES, NOT GOING TO LET
THIS BOTHER ME.
I THINK HE WAS, EVERY PRESIDENT
IS DEALT A CERTAIN HAND AND IT
DEPENDS ON HOW YOU PLAY IT.
HE WAS DEALT A PRETTY GOOD HAND
ON THE ECONOMY BUT HE PLAYED IT
VERY WELL.
THE ECONOMY IS IN A REALLY GOOD
PLACE RIGHT NOW AND THAT'S WHY I
THINK ONE OF THE THINGS THEY ARE
DOING TOMORROW IS GETTING
TOGETHER BECAUSE I HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT A SPENDING BILL, ALL
THESE THINGS BEFORE JANUARY 19.
IF THEY CAN GET IT DONE AND HE
HAS A CLEAN SLATE FOR THE STATE
OF THE UNION ON JANUARY 30, YOU
ALWAYS WANT TO SAY THAT THE
PRESIDENT HAS A VERY AMBITIOUS
AGENDA.
THE SECOND YEAR IS ALWAYS MORE
DIFFICULT THAN THE FIRST BUT
HE'S MUCH MORE CONSERVATIVE.
WE ARE GOING TO TALK ABOUT IRAN
NEXT.
>> Greg: I AM SAYING I AM
WRONG, JESSE, I WOULD GO, I
DON'T BELIEVE ANYTHING BECAUSE
OF THE PROTECTIONISM, I DIDN'T
BELIEVE HE WAS GOING TO BECOME
THIS CONSERVATIVE TYPE OF
LEADER, AND I THINK IT'S KIND OF
>> Dana: I FEEL LIKE HE HAS
SURROUNDED HIMSELF WITH REALLY
GOOD PEOPLE WHO ARE PERSUASIVE
IN THEIR ARGUMENTS.
HE HAD THE DEBATE OF THE
WHITE HOUSE ABOUT THE PARIS
ACCORDS AND THERE WAS A CERTAIN
GROUP OF THE WHITE HOUSE THAT
SAID YOU SHOULD STAY IN.
IT DOESN'T REALLY MATTER AND
IT'S BETTER DIPLOMATICALLY.
SCOTT PRUITT, THE EPA
ADMINISTRATOR SAID HERE'S FIVE
REASONS WE SHOULD GET OUT AND
LAID IT OUT AND HE LISTENED TO
HIM.
I THINK THAT'S TRUE IN SEVERAL
OF THESE OTHER ISSUES THAT HE
HAS SURROUNDED HIMSELF WITH GOOD
OF THE TYPE OF CONSERVATIVE
ESTABLISHMENT REPUBLICANS WILL
I TOOK OVER FOR JESSE.
IT'S >> Richard: THE QUESTION,
PULLING OUT OF THE PARIS ACCORDS
WHAT USED TO BE THE AMERICAN WAO
NORMS.
THAT CREATES A LARGER PROBLEM
FOR US.
A RECENT POLL IN GERMANY CAME
OUT THAT THE GERMANS TRUST THE
RUSSIANS, FOUND THE RUSSIANS
CREDIBLE THAN THE UNITED STATES.
>> Greg: WHY SHOULD WE CARE?
>> Richard: WE SHOULD CARE
ABOUT WHAT THE GERMANS THINK.
>> Greg: I CARE WHAT THE
AMERICANS THINK.
>> Kimberly: THIS IS WORSE
THAN A JUAN WILLIAMS POLL.
>> Richard: WE NEED THE
ON JOINT MILITARY OPERATIONS.
>> Dana: THEY WILL.
>> Richard: ON IRAN.
WE DON'T HAVE CREDIBILITY IN
EUROPE WHICH IS SUPPOSED TO BE,
>> Jesse: NO ONE IS GOING
ANYWHERE WITHOUT THE
UNITED STATES PAYING FOR NATO
AND NOW THEY ARE PAYING THEIR
FAIR SHARE.
U.N. SECURITY COUNCIL JUST
SLAPPED A FEW SANCTIONS ON
NORTH KOREA AND I THINK THERE'S
A FEW EUROPEAN COUNTRIES THERE.
>> Richard: I THINK WE ARE
SENDING OR GOODWILL FASTER THAN
WE HAVE IT.